all right y'all I'm still here keeping  up with my social distancing with my  family here in Montana this hour though  we're gonna be celebrating my new single  I dare you that I actually got to record  in six different languages which was  really a dream come true for me the song  is about love in all its forms in the  face of adversity you know choosing to  love instead of fear I'm proud that the  singers from all over the world sang  with me on this track I love all the  different languages I actually listen to  those more than the English version but  we're singing in their native languages  and we're so excited that we actually  have them on Zune today we have blast  from Espana we have Lucia from Morocco  we have Carolyn from Germany and we also  have Maya from Israel how y'all doing  subscribe to my channel subscribe to my  channel subscribe to my channel  subscribe to my channel please don't  make me keep going